你是不是也常常在想
那些站在金融世界金字塔顶端的人
他们成功的秘诀到底是什么
今天我们就来一起深入猜解一位
顶级交易员的四位核心
好首先你先看看这个数字
9000亿而且是台币
这个不是哪个小国家的GDP
这是一位专业交易员
短短五年内的总交易额
这个数字背后
到底藏了什么样的逻辑
这就让我们忍不住想问
他们的秘密究竟是什么
我跟你保健
这个问题的答案
可能会跟你想的完全不一样
OK 我们直接切入重点
要找到真相
我们得先打破一些
大家深信不疑的迷思
很多人都会觉得
要在市场上成功
尼玛要不是天生的奇才
就是手上有什么神秘的赚钱公事
再不然就是懂一些超级复杂的技术
但根据我们拿到的第一手词料
这位顶尖交易员的真实情况是
完全不是这么一回事
真正的秘诀其实比这些东西更简单
但也更强大
而且我们今天聊的这一切
都不是我们自己乱猜的
全部都是来自这份
可以说是超级超级难得的第一手交易员讲座笔记这样我们有机会一窥真实的交易世界好那接下来真正有趣的部分要开始了
接下来我们就要来揭晓
支撑这一切的那个唯一的关键概念
这个外面就叫做正期望值
我知道我知道
这听起来是不是有点学术对吧
但你别担心我们马上把它变得很简单
它的核心意思其实就是
在你做了超级超级多笔交易之后
你平均下来
每一笔交易都是赚钱的
就这样
你可以把想象成开间赌场
赌场老板的目标
从来就不是要赢过每一个客人不是吗
他靠的是那个微小
但长期下来绝对存在的数学优势
来确保这门生意稳赚不赔
嗯
这就是正其忘值的威力
所以你看
这个听起来好像很深奥的概念
落到实际操作上
就简化成了一个超级清楚的决策SOP
第一
如果期望值是正的
那你就做
第二
如果期望值是负的
那你就休息
不要动
对
就是这么简单
这么干脆
如果原则就这么简单
那问题来咯
真正的差别到底在哪里
你会发现
关键根本不是什么魔法
而是你的心态
对啊
那这就带出一个很有趣的问题了如果核心概面真的就这样而已那到底是什么东西把那些顶尖高手跟我们一般人给彻彻底底的区分开来了
在那份原始的笔记里面
有一句话我觉得形容的
真的太传神了
他说大多数人听到
市场集会的时候
就停留在吃瓜群众的状态
什么意思
意思就是
他们只是把市场消息
当成茶余饭后的八卦新闻
听一听聊一聊
然后呢
就没有然后了
你看这个对比
真的是天差地远
左边的吃瓜群众
他们眼中看到的是什么
是新闻
是小道消息
是各种市场的杂音
他们被这些东西淹没
觉得很困惑
但你看右边的专业人士
他们看到的
却是完全不一样的风景
他们看到的是
可以用的原始材料
是数据
是可以发展成策略的
潜在机会
好那问题来了
高手是怎么做到的
他们是怎么样
把观察到的现象
一步一步打造成
可以稳定执行的策略的呢
这就是他们一套
系统化的流程
第一步
观察到一个市场现象
第二步
重点来了
他不把这个当八卦
而是当成非常珍贵的
策略素材
第三步呢
他会对这个初步的想法
开始层层叠加去打磨加入各种滤网跟条件到最后第四步形成一个可以重复验证可以实际操作的方法所以你懂了吗真正的分页点就在这里
真正困难的工作
从来就不是去大海捞针
想找到什么天大的秘密
而是透过一个有纪律的过程
建立起你自己的逻辑系统
成功不是来自于某一次幸运的发现
而是来自于这个
你可以不断重复
不断优化的系统
讲到这里,我们来到最后一部分。
我们来看看这一切对你来说到底该怎么应用,你该如何建立属于自己的优势。
帮大家快速总结一下今天的几个关键tag away。
第一,成功是来自流程,不是来自天赋。
第二,正期望之是你唯一的北极星,是你做决策的最高指导原则。
第三停止在当一个市场噪音的消费者
开始去当一个策略素材的收集者
最后也是最重要的
你的终极目标是建立一个属于你自己的
独一无二的逻辑框架
所以从今天起
下一次当你再看到一则市场新闻的时候
你可以问问自己
我现在看到的究竟是等一下就消失的噪音
还是可以让我打造成策略的珍贵素材
我想这个问题的答案
可能就是你迈向专业之路的起点